uh let's talk about some NBA stuff I
mean can we even talk about the NBA yet
no I think it's hard because it's it's
you're not fully developed yet you know
I mean wait what are you trying to say
this season is what it's like a it's
like a minor it's the minor things only
it's just minoring this is childish it's
childish it's childish you talk about
the NBA this season is in its infancy
did I hear you say infancy it's in its
infancy got you I got you okay and we're
not pointing at anything specific no no
at all no um would y'all [__] a 16
why do you bring that up hypothetical
purely hypothetical yeah complete
complete like would you rather do would
you rather okay yeah would you rather
like have a flourishing NBA career get a
Max contract make hundreds of millions
of dollars and have generational wealth
or [__] a 16y could chose knowing she's
a 16-year-old I don't know I I don't
know about that okay but would you be
like a little bit more scrupulous in
your vetting knowing that you have all
that to lose yeah I would scrutinize a
little more yeah yeah the wrong word I
think it still works so I didn't say it
was wrong scrupulous means moral which
still kind of works but yeah scrutinized
would be like vetting it more chosen
one yeah even when I'm wrong I'm right
fail
[Applause]
successfully okay uh obviously we're
talking about um Carl Malone
yeah leg no no there's these allegations
against Josh giddy plays for OKC right
and that like some girl posted some
picture of him saying yo I just [__]
Josh Giddy and she's I think a junior in
high school which would make her how old
Al you would know or would mark would
knowk would know make her 18 miles you
definitely no so so here's the thing he
played the next night that's crazy no
it's not to me that shows that he didn't
do
anything like in my opinion if he if he
actually did something and he came to
cuz the organizations's coming to him
immediately and they're going like yo
what the [__] is going on here did you
do anything illegal
maybe where he lives or where the girl
live one of those I looked it up I
already looked it up just to see for the
for the Pod I I looked it up for the Pod
break the whole thing true I looked it
up for research bro I looked up weird go
go go you don't me to look it up you
don't me to have I'm glad I'm not I'm
glad you did the research thank you go
go listen we just have to bag on you for
being weird we all want to know what is
the age of consent in Oklahoma let's
just a guess 15
I don't know I'm a yeah I was thinking
early maybe 16 cuz I know New York's 17
which I think is
weird 16 years old okay so this is my
suspicion they come to him they go yo
what the [__] is going on and he goes I
didn't know this that the other and they
vet the actual age and then they go
technically he didn't do anything
illegal he can
play if they if he went to them and he
has to be honest right there's a lot of
[__] riding on them there's going to be
like legal action it's going to reflect
on the organization they're going to
go they're going to go uh oh actually
look at the agent consent in Australia I
just looked it up Jesus Christ what the
hell Florida Bo he's
Florida it is between 16 and 17
depending on the state so the he Josh
gidd is from Australia okay so the
assumption is does he believe it's okay
and then do it right and then the organ
ation is like even though this is the
creepiest [__] disgusting thing that
you're out here hooking up with high
school girls technically it's not
illegal therefore we can't ban him we
can't put him in jail he's going to play
but didn't so John Mor was he breaking
gun laws where he was because he got
suspended I think the NBA has a uh a
behavioral clause and behavioral Clause
is not an issue to [__] 16-year-olds I
it might it might literally they might
need to add it they might need to add
that come on bro you know what that is I
I don't want to say that I don't it
doesn't add up to me that he's still
playing at all that's the thing like the
fact that he play the next day made me
think he didn't [__] yes he did she's
he's in a picture with her shirtless the
girl posted a picture saying I just [__]
giddy which makes me think she didn't do
it no girls is they
[__] you don't take that many can can
you look up the eye just [__] Josh gy
picture please sorry I know it just
makes me think he didn't she didn't do
it because she would also assume that
that's incriminating right she's
basically going yo this guy just stat
raped me no but I think both of them
she's looking at him like yo I want to
[__] NBA star and he's like you know
this girls also it's excuse you should
[__] know yeah like I don't care what
the age is in Australia they're not
[__] idiots out there like your whole
career is coming here you're not going
to learn the basic minimum hey don't
[__] young girls yeah I saw one thing
that said it was known that he liked
young girls I don't know if that's real
or not but like somebody at some point
has probably said and they train up
every NBA rookie or whatever stay away
from XYZ I'm sure as many in look at
this just [__] Josh giddy he's shirtless
in the picture yeah come on why are you
shortless in a picture with a
16-year-old girl okay Mark tell us I
don't
know tell us yeah what maybe they're
doing a workout maybe he's a he's a
coach of the high school basketball team
maybe they're just family in the house
you know chilling yeah maybe that's his
sister bro she looks Australian then
they did [__] though that's his sister
that's my point
so what
happens I don't know he's not even good
enough to keep around is what's crazy oh
is he not that good I thought he I
thought he was nice I thought he was I
think he's doing it he's fine as far as
I know he winged that [__] he did you do
an India thing yeah he winged that
Hindustan it I think you hind stand that
he's not even John Morant we're not
protecting johnar we protected the [__]
out if he just kept doing it johnar
could do anything he wanted he was
pulling guns out in [__] pick a
basketball games like J got a lot of
protection yeah I did get also what he
did was more obvious I guess as like a
violation for the NBA like we don't have
like confirmation video the NBA thought
they didn't have to tell their players
you can't [__] 16-year-
olds and then this [__] cokehead from
Australia shows up and he starts
smashing them out and taking pictures
with them the picture is crazy this is
that's what I'm saying he doesn't think
anything's wrong but maybe he did but
you should you should know yo it's like
that baseball player there was did you
guys hear about this baseball player I'm
a [__] up where he's from I don't know
if he from Dominican Republic or
something like that but he had like
13-year-old girlfriends oh did you know
hear about I think he was like he got
like some hundred million contract or
whatever but he was like dating like 13y
olds and [__] and I think people like oh
he didn't know it's like no you know
you're being a [__] Creek yeah yeah I
mean this is crazy I mean that's a crazy
picture if he goes I'm I was drunk why
are you drunk with you can't say that
[__] 16y olds well I think he's also
20 I don't even know if it's legal for
him to drink but if short
and if this is in Oklahoma where it's
legal then he's like I'm not doing
anything wrong he's
21 it's not that far it's weird but it
ain't that far know bro nah but look at
him he look do you know you got millions
why do you know why do I know why does
Mark know why does akos know why does
this guy not everybody
know you got millions on the line yo yo
who doesn't know just saying I ain't
going to say d
who doesn't know yo hey who doesn't know
I know I'm just saying so it's like I
it's weird it's creepy you should this
man married his
teenager that's legal that's legal bro
true that's legal yo Jos Josh got to
make a wife out of her yo Josh you got
one chance for Retribution you got a
wife for yo yeah that is a good point
that's the only way that's the only way
cuz don't they have like some rules
where it's like if the age is like stop
acting n isn't there a
rule it's called the Romeo and Juliet
CLA wait why do you know it why do you
know
it come on
out dare dare
[Laughter]
[__] I knew if it's close enough they
let you they give you a little wiggle
real son does Biden need to come out and
just tell [__] you can't [__]
16 year old it's like 18 yo I don't know
if he B didn't just say 18 you think he
was goingon to say that though what Mr
sniffing heads you think with
numbers I don't think he's the one yeah
oh God yeah because the thing is like
even if nothing happens to him even if
he keeps on playing there's no problem
it's going to follow him
forever like it's just going to be nons
I saw a video the other day or just like
today it was like dude tying a shoe in
front of like a bunch of kids did you
see this video like I some NBA play
might have been like LeBron I don't even
know you could just see his foot and he
ties a shoe in front of the kids and
runs away and it's these two girls that
are like 10 they're like oh my gosh an
NBA player was just near us all the
comments oh they just saw Josh kiddy
like all like just yeah every comment no
he's going to be the most famous
pedophile for sure like and he they
asked him in the interviews that might
be defamation you can't say allegedly
cuz it's like you can't really even
though it's weird you can't put it on
them if it's legal you can't yeah can yo
and it's that weird [__] of
[__] who like really they look
around pile is not a legal term
pedophile is just a thing it's a label
you're [__] a 16-year-old to me
you're a pedophile that's not legal like
like that's it you're I don't give a
[__] we using it as slang
yeah we using it as slang bro yo we can
call our class a mud [__] we can't
call him a kid [__] low key like we
throwing it out there you never Fu you
never even [__] 16year olds and you got
discipline I got discipline you know me
got discipline discipline I keep it in
my pants this guy don't this might be
wild but I bet you her parents don't
mind it might be wild why you protecting
this man so much weird why you
protecting him I'm saying the bad the
bad parents the bad par because if this
is a 16-year-old and you're [__] step
chatting guys you [__] already the
parents done [__] up you think she got
yeah yeah she ain't got no she ain't on
a poll she got one she ain't on a poll
she kind of was you how he built he's
six sage you know what I mean she was
dancing just like the rest nah she ain't
got no [__] for the we also don't have a
confirmed age I looked it up yeah it's
not it's not confirmed she's a junior in
high school unless she's [__] how
about you start with this [__] that's
not confirmed either we don't we don't
know exactly how old she is so then
what's this whole rumor they deleted
everything so they had a I think it was
like a picture of her from like last
year she's like in high school last year
so I think the speculation that she's
like a junior so this this could be an
18-year-old [__] and we talking for no
[__] reason right now nowah she's 18
and we got to apologize to Josh G I
don't know what the conf is if she was
18 he'd have said she's
18 that's a good ass point he refused to
answer questions if you were [__] if
you were [__] an 18-year-old [__]
and everybody's like yo she's 15 what
would the first thing you say I can't
comment on that or you show her ID yeah
I would ask for ID look how old this
[__] no people asking you f you know
she's 18 for a fact you're right she's
18 and people like yo I heard you [__]
a 15-year-old what do you say I have no
comment or you say n she's 18 [__] you I
got proof I'd leave with that unless I
had a legal counsel was like hey don't
say anything no
[__] [__] [__] the legal counsel if the
legal counsel was like hey don't say
she's 18 I'd be like I need new legal
counsel Fu you it's like when San dusy
[__] up that question and they were
like are you attracted to young boys and
he was like what do you mean attracted
or
Kell the
teenager yeah yeah yeah so yeah you
can't fumble that if you know you're
innocent you just got to be like that's
why I don't think he's innocent also
there's a picture of this girl saying
she just [__] Josh giddy yeah that's
enough of me is this racism is Josh kidy
only getting preferential treatment
because he's well we don't know if he's
getting preferential treatment bro can
we talk about JFK someone else receiving
head
shot sloppy head in the back go to priz
pick.com use a promo code Schultz don't
match your initial entry of $100 up to
that $100 so you put 100 they're going
to match up to 100 exactly that's
beautiful you said that better than me
listen we in this together we're Team
okay we are teams go to priz pi.com get
that 100% deposit match up to $100 with
the promo code SH SZ you got this okay
now let's get back to the sh